19 jahre weiblich servus s kids und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
ich habe heute aus den tiefen des
internets eine internetseite ausgegraben
die schon lange vergessen war wie man
dachte mir daran das wird mal existierte
diese website ist der haut puncto und
heute checken wir wer von all den
youtuber in youtube deutschland der
aller geizte ist wer sieht am besten aus
heute der test freund ich hoffe ich bin
es ehrlich gesagt die suche zu diesem
zweck instagram bilder von allen
möglichen youtube an raus wenn ich noch
eine folge machen soll könnt ihr mal in
die kommentare schreiben wenig in der
nächsten folge analysieren sollte erst
youtuber den leuten chatten ist einer
der sehr sehr viel kritik sehr viel fett
abbekommen in letzter zeit den ich
persönlich das sage ich nicht zu viel
mainstream youtuber eigentlich in
ordnung findet der ist mir einfach
sympathisch weil der ausdruck komplett
gestört im kopf ist wie ich die rede ist
von niemand geringerem als freak und
jetzt schicken wir hier was wird er von
rating bekommen gleich fünf oder sechs
stufen hot okay wir haben 1 2 3 4 5 6
stufen gesamten okay nice hot stunning
und gott like als ich gerade import
testläufe mit der seite gemacht habe hat
die eigentlich bestens funktioniert aber
wir schauen uns kurz mal dieses bild an
ok power hat punkto denkt sein hals ist
ein gesicht und er ist 50 jahre alt wie
er schrieb wenn du das hier siehst wenn
heißt sieht so aus als wäre 50 aber er
ist immer noch hat auch im alter von 50
jahren vielleicht noch ein anderes foto
ich meine die bewertung des gehalts
schönheit war schon topf aber für mein
zweites und
ok also dieses viereck was sie da sehen
ja das sollte eigentlich über dem
gesicht sein die ganze fläche die dieses
viereck abdeckt ist das gesicht und wir
schauen was dazu zählt auf jeden fall
die iphone-kamera definitiven teil des
gesichtes die goldkette absolut detail
des kleiderschranks im hintergrund
selbstverständlich leute sagen diese
mischung aus kleiderschrank oberarm
iphone kamera und goldkette und noch ein
bisschen gesicht hat sich auch nicht
schlecht gehalten 37 jahre alt und
männlich sagt die seite opel astra wird
die seite kriegs gesicht akzeptieren in
einem letzten versuch
es hat funktioniert er hat hot er hat
hot bekommen ich weiß ehrlich gesagt
nicht wie gut hat ist ungefähr alter 24
jahre ist auch gar nicht so schlecht ich
weiß aber nicht leute was die seite bei
den vorherigen fotos geritten hat okay
leute ihr seht schon hier wir gehen von
extremer zu extremer von k s freak zu
luca richtig gespannt was der
schatzkiste ist nur was mir gerade durch
den kopf geht ich möchte euch mit dem
video jetzt nicht vermitteln dass es das
wichtigste ist wie eine person aussieht
oder dass man leute nach ihrem aussehen
so kaske werden sollte und sagen sollte
alle die nicht so super aussehen wie
scheiße oder so ich mache das heute
einfach als gag ich hoffe ihr versteht
das was wirklich nur gesagt dann ganz
schöne schelle von dem bot alter da
werden einige fans nicht zufrieden sein
wir geben luca noch eine chance wenn ihr
noch ein bild gemacht aber auch echt
eigentlich verdammt wenige bilder wo er
sein gesicht zeit okay hier blues lose
lose lose you can do bietet bord anlauf
nummer zwei für luca und gerade immer
den ice bekommen und 20 jahre
[Musik]
alter schwede gott like und 23 jahre das
ist relativ akkurat und er hat
tatsächlich das gesicht erkannt und ich
bin smaghi auf dem pulli ausgewählt als
gesicht da setzt wird es jetzt echt mal
die maßstäbe hier gott like habe ich
bisher noch überhaupt nicht gesehen
ehrlich gesagt in der auswertung okay
machen wir weiter leute und ich denke
mir ich will einfach auch wirklich nur
bilder aus wo die leute gut getroffen
sind also gibt ja auch ins programm auch
einige bilder wo die leute einfach
scheiße drauf aussehen aber jetzt haben
wir hier den jüngling meinen kleinen
bruder max karl crafter und ich bin
gespannt ob er im battle auf die youtube
uploads schlagen kann
goal.com hat vor gott gleich was krass
alter auf corot ganz ehrlich findet ihr
der unterschied zwischen lokal max ist
so groß na ja das kann ich ein wobei
luca hat ja auch erst noch ob glaube ich
nie er hatte nur nice auf dem ersten
bild wenn wir noch ein zweites auto max
also ihr merkt schon leute wir müssen
ein bisschen durch mixen wir müssen mehr
als ein bild nehmen wir müssen wir zwei
oder drei projekte übernehmen um dann
geschah das bild zu erhalten und jetzt
jammert wie sein kumpel raul ist auch
noch mit halb ich hoffe das erkennt max
als als das gesicht im bild
[Musik]
sich zum zweiten mal gott leiter
spotlight kombination der wade erst so
dass auf jeden fall macht holt auf gott
michael auch die volle punktzahl und
leute maxime lukas schon gestellt max
und luca haben beide mit einem bild gold
geholt
jetzt bin ich dran bei ok ich hab' das
erste bild von mir ausgewählten es noch
mit langen haaren ich habe nur bilder
mit langlauf instagram erstes bild ist
schon anfang wollte ich kann die kann
ich ohne goldlack herausgehen aber ist
dann ist auch schon mal nicht schlecht
kann man schon machen und ich habe doch
einfach nicht so viele instagram bilder
oder nummer zwei bitte gib mir einfach
gleich stunning ist nicht genug leute
das ist eine dumme aussage das zu sagen
aber es ist nicht genug wir brauchen
gott lichtbild könnte es seien deutlich
mehr instrument wieder mit meinen kurzen
haaren machen glaube ich okay alles klar
der letzte versuch am baum und der
website the face
die konnten kein gesicht entdecken in
der bild ich habe karten bild formierung
was fehlt die gekonnte kein gesicht der
wurde mich flachsen ist ziemlich sicher
ein gesicht hat der farc alter ich hab
ich nur kurz das bild was ich hochladen
wollte dass hier das bild über die
hochladen
wo ist da bitte kein gesicht was soll er
sonst seine fucking strandkrabbe oder
wie ein bild noch ein bild meine
erwartungshaltung hat sich so langsam
leicht verändert von ich hätte gern gott
live könnt ihr bitte einfach mein
verdammtes gesicht den bildern erkennen
ich mein das erst mal 50.000 das bild
gibt mir jetzt einfach mal komm schon 19
jahre weiter
erstmal internetblog aktiviert ich habe
euch vertraut machen ich habe eure
website in video benutzt wachsen gibt
ihr beide gottgleich aus dem nichts ok
sania es war okay ich wollte mir haben
und dann 19 jahre und weiblich alte
leute ein anderer sehr berühmt der
youtuber verletzt youtuber der heute
analysiert wird ist leer
und wenn lehrer und mehr punkte holt
sich in diesem test dann lösche ich
meine tube kanal zu kanal behalten das
heißt wir sind es beim nächsten video
wieder bis dahin haut rein macht's gut
und radio